welcome to get cooking in cloud where we
share the best recipes to apply in your
cloud kitchen
I am Priyanka and in this episode we'll
share the recipe to set up a cold dr
pattern for applications that are
primarily deployed on-premise so let's
dive in
[Music]
your dr plan would depend on your
specific application and recovery goals
let's consider a few scenarios to
understand this if you run batch
processing workloads they tend to be non
mission-critical and don't need to be
designed for high availability in such
cases you would use preemptable virtual
machine instances in conjunction with
Google Cloud Storage and that's your dr
plan if you run an e-commerce site then
the actual purchasing pipeline needs to
have high availability but the email
process that sends those notifications
to customers can tolerate a bit of delay
this is a mix of hot purchasing and warm
or cold notification patterns if you
have a video streaming solution then
from the search to actually streaming
content the entire experience needs to
be AJ or the customer might turn to your
competitor let's talk about an
interesting company main street art they
run their application on-premise and are
building a DR infrastructure on google
cloud they are now working out a
disaster recovery plan with a low budget
and are okay with a bit high RPO and RTO
values this means they need to set up a
cold dr pattern in cold dr pattern Main
Street art needs minimal resources in
the dr google cloud project just enough
to enable the recovery scenario when a
disaster occurs the failover strategy
requires a mirror of the production
environment to be started in google
cloud let's see how this would work we
create a VPC network then we configure
the connectivity between the on-premise
Network and the Google cloud network we
need a cloud storage pocket as the
target for our backup data now for your
on-premise machine to upload database
backups to Google cloud we will need a
service account key to authenticate your
machine within an automated script we
would use iam policies to restrict
access to
right user as well as ensure that the
service account has the minimal
permissions required and make sure
uploads and downloads to and from the
cloud storage bucket are working then
you finally stripped the data transfer
create a scheduled task to run that
script and then create custom images
that are configured for each type of
server in the production environment you
configure the DNS to point to your
internet facing web services and then
create a deployment manager template
that will create servers in your Google
cloud network using the previously
configured custom images when a disaster
hits all you need is to execute the
deployment manager template which will
create a Google cloud deployment
automatically apply the most recent
database backups and transaction locks
from the cloud storage bucket test the
application works as expected by
simulating a user in the recovered
environment then finally point the cloud
DNS to the web server on Google cloud
when the production environment is
running on premise again and the
environment can support production
workloads we reverse the steps that we
followed typically it goes something
like this
take a backup and transaction logs of
the database running on Google Cloud
copy and applied the backup files to the
database in production environment at
this stage you should prevent
connections to the application in Google
cloud or you can stop the connections
after the database have been
successfully restored and apply any
transactions that occurred after the
backup was taken in our case we need to
stop the connections to the global load
balancer from this point your
application will be unavailable until
you finish restoring the production
environment configure cloud DNS to point
to your on-premise web service ensure
that the process you had in place to
copy data to cloud storage is operating
as expected
then finally delete your deployments
there you have it if you are running
your application on-premise and have a
constrained budget and can work with
high RTO and RPO values then a cold dr
pattern is the way to go we learn how to
approach recovering the environment from
failure in a cold dr scenario that's all
for today
on get cooking in cloud here's hoping
you're cooking up your own dr strategy
join us next time where we will share
the recipe to implement a warm stand by
dr pattern for Main Street Park if you
would like to see more such content
don't forget to Like and subscribe to
our Channel
[Music]